in 1988 a fellow classmate mr. Siraj
boss Archana wrote a letter to Stanford
GSB community saying I'm seeing a lot of
tears being shed at the end of her NBA
career
my classmates are saying I wish I'd
spent more time with my friends
and less time getting higher and higher
grades after a few years mr. Shue sad
rolled back and he said in the real
world no one has ever asked me about my
grades at all instead I have constantly
leveraged the intra and interpersonal
learnings that I've gotten interacting
with my classmates how are we spending
our time here at the GSB
my name is roll and today I want to talk
to you about how I found out that
relationships are the most important
part of my life even more important than
external measures of success such as
money or even my career I'll share with
you a study from a group of Grayson
university professors where they found
that levels of self-reported happiness
actually increased with income and money
and this correlation helped true up
until $75,000 but after an annual income
of $75,000 people weren't any happier
what I suggest is that any extra time
that you're spending on getting more
than $75,000 a year it's time that you
could spend on your friends your
relationships or your family
how do you want to spend that extra time
let me tell you how I answered that
question the hard way ever since I was a
kid I only wanted to do things right I
wanted to be the best at what I did and
schoolwork wasn't the exception I went
into this high demanding high school
program that demanded a lot of time and
sacrifices of me I worked hard I missed
family events amidst trips miss social
events and I missed on a lot of friends
but I thought it's worth it I'm working
for the most important thing in my life
it's my career it's worth it
have you ever heard the song cat's in
the cradle if you haven't heard the song
it's about a son that tells his father
that he wants to spend time with him but
the father is always too busy and he
says you know we'll have a good time
then right but that time never comes the
future comes and they never spend that
good time my case was a reverse back in
high school I was working really hard I
remember being in my room doing all my
homework
and I remember my dad coming in my room
and saying hey Raul do you want to spend
some time do you want to hang out you
want to watch a program watch TV and I
remember feeling angry desperate
impatient because he felt that he didn't
understand me I was working so hard to
be the best I could the best son the
best student working so hard for these
things that were the most important
things in my life and he didn't see that
so I said no
after I finished high school I got into
the site elite school I went to Cornell
and I was doing taking some interesting
classes I was doing sports but as a year
went by I slowly realized I was unhappy
I was puzzled I didn't know why I was
living the dream I was in an Ivy League
school I had gotten everything that I
wanted but I wasn't happy
like what's supposed to be perfect but
it was not when my year ended I went
back to Monterey Mexico and I was
thinking who do I want to become what do
I want to remember of myself at the end
of my life and I realized I did not have
the answers to those questions so I
thought maybe I need some time off just
that idea scared me I didn't know where
it was gonna take me I was so focused on
a certain path that I was scared to even
try anything else but I knew I needed
the time so I took time off and did not
go back to school over those years I
took off I started talking to people
that I trusted I started writing in my
journal a lot and I did some research I
found that there's a nurse called
Bronnie ware who works in Australia with
generally ill patients in the last weeks
of their lives and she found across
hundreds of patients that they had one
thing in common they all said I wish I
hadn't worked so hard I wish
and I'd spent more time with my family
and friends
I then bumped into a book called happy
for no reason
and in the book there was a study that
said that people that valued wealth
power and Status over close
relationships where twice as slightly to
report being fairly or very unhappy and
in a study by the University of Chicago
they found that people with five or more
close relationships were 50% more likely
to report being very happy now
I knew that relationships were the most
important parts of my life
and I knew I had made some bad decisions
in the past especially saying no to my
dad I decided to change I set up a
weekly lunch with my dad just by
ourselves you talk and get to know
ourselves better I reconnected with old
friends
they formed the soccer team with them I
met new people made great new buddies I
even met my wife my life was a lot
happier and I was back on track
a few months ago here at Stanford I
attended a talk about relationships in
this talk we had GSB students and
medical students another spoon from the
University but after two hours of
discussion I found out that most of us
with relationships way below input our
studies or work everything else about
relationships and we just thought that
relationships will work out by
themselves but let me tell you that
that's not true but I found out from
those years back then is that if you
want rates and fruitful relationships in
your life you need to work partly and I
realized that I need to remind myself of
that every day I want to share with you
and analogy made by a former CEO of
coca-cola called Brian Dyson he said
imagine life is like a game where you're
juggling a set of balls you name them
work family spirit friends you will soon
find out
that work is like a rubber ball if you
drop it he'll bounce back but family and
friends if you drop them they will break
looking back at my life I realized I
hadn't juggled that well at times I've
been close to dropping the most
important parts of my life but now I
know that relationships are first for me
favorite percent the true currency of
happiness today I invite you to reflect
on how you want to juggle the aspects of
your life and which of those aspects you
don't want